when I started learning English and
French at school back in the days I was
frustrated because every time I tried to
say something my mind and my brain
constantly resorted to my native
language hi my name is Luca from Luca
imperio comm and today I'm going to talk
about how to think directly in your
target language let's get started so
truth be told I was quite frustrated but
with time and experience and the more
languages that I learned I just realized
that this is completely normal
reversing reverting converting and
resorting to your native language is
just a natural process if you think
about it that makes sense because the
brain always takes new pieces of
information from the outside from the
environment and associates these pieces
of information with old pieces of
information that it has stored so you
should not be scared of translating I've
heard so many people countless times say
that you have to stay away from your
native language you have to stay away
from translation but the truth is you
can actually use your own native
language and leverage the knowledge in
your own native language to learn new
languages new things new words an
example of that is Italian in Spanish I
am a native Italian speaker and for me I
would not go so far as to say that
learning Spanish was a piece of cake but
having the two languages that that's
similar and being able to compare and
translate was a huge help let me give an
example if you don't know Spanish or if
you don't know a time value and are a
Alomar a perk a tempo a bellow quiero
ear al Ahmar porque el tiempo esta
stupendo es estupendo well you can
compare these two and if you compare it
side-by-side you will realize that the
structure is almost the same and the
words are almost the same so the bottom
line here is that if you are a native
Italian speaker learning Spanish by
using translation will actually be a
huge advantage in this regard you can
see your native language like a
companion that takes you hand by hand or
with whom you walk hand by
and for the first stretch of the long
journey ahead he will be with you and he
will be a great help
then when you are more autonomous and
you know your way you will be able to
walk alone so if on one hand I think the
translation is great you have to be
cautious with it and you have to learn
how to translate let me give you another
example Japanese is quite different from
Spanish and of course from Italian so if
on one hand Italian and Spanish are very
similar are very close in linguistic
terms Italian and Japanese are very very
distant and not just in terms of words
but also in terms of syntax that is how
we arrange things and how we arrange a
sentence value and arielle matter per km
per bed I want to go to the sea because
the weather is great
so in Japanese you would say that tank
eegah ii kara q WA you meanie iki Titus
which means you know I have to think
about it
thank you God like the weather II good
Cara since kya today you mean e to the C
iki Titus I want to go and as you can
see the structure is quite different you
have to rearrange the the words in a
completely different way and that adds
an extra step and it's an extra some
extra effort for your brain because you
not only have to think about the words
the meaning you have to take them a
rearrange them like a puzzle so in this
case translation can be somewhat you
know laborious and one piece of advice
that I have given to myself with time
and I've just realized it is that so the
question was should I just like stop
translating Japanese and the answer was
no but simplify it when we try to sound
sophisticated and say things that are a
little bit too complicated what happens
is our our brain reverse to a defense
mechanism says woohoo stop there
it's this is too difficult we're trying
to say things very often that are too
difficult because we just don't have the
tools so what to do well just break
things down the most important thing is
not performance you of course you want
to sound smart right but the most
important thing is always communication
it's always getting your point across
it's always to make that person a smile
or connect with you or share thoughts
the point is I want to go to the sea and
the weather is beautiful and you put
these things together one after the
other you break down these sentences by
simply say for example today the weather
is beautiful I want to go to the sea
that is easier in Japanese because
you're shortening sentences and in that
case your brain will actually say okay
you're letting me breathe and it will be
much easier to stick to Japanese instead
of resorting to your own native language
that's a very important key point to
take away
[Music]
sure there are many techniques that you
can use in order to get your point
across improve your communication skills
be more direct more concise talk to
people that's all fantastic but the
truth is that language learning happens
first and foremost through input and
massive input at that if you want to
sound almost like a native speaker or
simply acquire native like skills what
you have to do is get massive input get
exposed to a lot of things and I'm not
just referring to a lot of audio or a
lot of books a lot of these things all
of these things think about what a
native speaker did so reading books
watching documentaries watching movies
listening to podcasts all the things you
can think of that you like doing in your
own native language or what you did just
do them in your target language because
that is going to influence not so much
of course also your conscious mind run
first and foremost the subconscious part
of your mind and remember that the brain
is like a recorder it records everything
so the more you expose yourself to
situations to people to books to
documentaries to everything you can
think of the better it is I am pretty
sure that sometimes you found yourself
saying something or knowing something
that you think where did I learn this
how do I know this that's because your
mind learns also subconsciously you
never have to forget that so whatever
you do great get a you know get on skype
talk to people do this do that do
something deliberately but on top of
that make sure and never forget to get
massive input as much as you can because
that is also going to influence the way
you're going to speak here now and in
the long term
so to do a quick wrap-up the three
important things to keep in mind are
first of all don't be scared of using
your own native language it's inevitable
make it to your advantage
leverage it build short sentences and
then learn to link them together and
progressively expend them because the
main point is not performance it's
always first and foremost communication
and the third thing to keep in mind is
that language learning happens
unconsciously and consciously and to
make it very strong you have to combine
the two
so get massive input through every
single channel that you can fathom and
you can think of because that's going to
make the difference in the short run as
well as in the long run so here you have
it I truly hope you like the video and
if you want to know more I've written an
extensive article that you can also
listen to on top of reading on my
website Luka lamp a Telecom you can
click on the link below and again thanks
for watching and see you very soon here
on YouTube
[Music]
you
[Music]
you